the main problem that we face is that
our current growth is not at a recovery
speed so what a recovery means is that
you grow at more than the rate that you
averaged over the past in order to
recover you got to get back to where you
were and so if you had a shock like a
big recession that we just encountered
we have to grow at more than the
long-term rate so the long-term rate in
the United States is about 3% we usually
grow at about 3% per year unfortunately
since the recovery we've been growing
not at a rate above 3% which is what we
need to get back but actually at a rate
below 3% so rather than recovering we're
actually getting further and further
away from where we need to be
so we need to get on a better trajectory
and the best way to do that is to
increase investment to increase
productivity and I view that as coming
primarily from four policies one is a
lower and better more efficient tax code
two would be a better regulatory
structure so a more cautious eye to
regulation and regulation that enhances
economic growth the third would be
getting the budget under control so not
growing the debt at record paces and the
fourth would be engaging in more
international trade if you look at the
US population we're less than five
percent of the world right now we're a
much bigger part of the world economy
but in order to continue that that
status in the world in terms of economic
structure we've got to be using the rest
of the world as our market and not just
the United States and that means more
trade we've been way too reluctant to
extend our trade over the past three to
four years and we need to do that more
much more aggressively most economists
believe that we should move to something
like a consumption tax what is a
consumption tax it means it only taxes
consumption it does not tax income there
are a variety of technical reasons for
that but this is pretty much
uncontroversial in the sense that almost
all economists think this is the best
way to go the problem is making it
progressive so the easiest way to do
that would be to keep something like the
current progressive tax structure but to
allow for no taxation of investment if
you do that you're basically saying we
tax only consumption a variety of ways
to do that again this is technical stuff
but the simplest way to do that is to
allow businesses to expense that means
deduct from their taxes all investment
that they make
that's a pro-growth strategy and it's
one that most economists tend to like
even if you tax the rich as much as you
can possibly tax the rich again using
the president's numbers there's just no
way we're going to even come close to
closing the gap between his projected
spending and his projected tax revenue
by taxing the rich that's already built
into his numbers and we can't get there
so what that implies is that if we want
to continue on this path of spending we
will have to raise the average tax for
the average American by 50%
that means everybody would be paying
about 50% more in taxes the most likely
way that that would come about would be
to impose a v80 tax which is like a
federal retail sales tax on the economy
that would have negative impacts on
economic growth and so you know that
would basically make us look a lot more
like Europe we have very large projected
increases in spending most of this comes
from Medicare and Medicaid Social
Security is also a problem but Social
Security is a problem that most people
think we can deal with more readily
there are some pretty clean solutions to
that problem Medicare and Medicaid are
much more problematic as we look down
the road and what we need to do is not
cut Medicare and Medicaid but we need to
figure out ways to limit the growth in
those expenditures to move to a more
efficient healthcare system that
probably means more incentives on the
margin for people to bear their own
costs of their own health care make
decisions in a more rational way some of
the Obamacare measures are tries our
attempts to move in that direction we'll
see if they work many of the Obamacare
measures are subsidies to the middle
class that actually work in the wrong
direction so net you know we'll have to
see if that's cost saving the president
claims they are I think many are
skeptical that they will be cost saving
in the long run I think most people who
have analyzed that including the
Congressional Budget Office have altered
their opinions and revised upward the
cost associated with president's health
care bill but we'll see
I think that the Republican view that
you should not raise taxes and that you
have to focus on the spending side comes
from the view that incentives matter and
incentives matter a whole lot and if you
start taxing people eventually the money
is going to move abroad and by the way
that's not because Americans are going
to invest elsewhere the marginal dollar
of investment in the United States is
not coming from an American it's coming
from a Brit or from a Dutch person or
from a German who's investing in the
United States and they can go anywhere
with their money so as we start raising
taxes those money those dollars are
going to go elsewhere and that's the
concern I think the Democrats have a
somewhat different view their view is
that we can do a good bit of
redistribution help the poor to a
significant extent without too much
effect on incentives without too much
effect on growth
during their session productivity
actually went up and you'd say I could
productivity go up during a recession
that's weird well the reason for that is
that what happened was although output
fell demand for products fell employment
fell by even more so what that means is
that the remaining workers actually had
to work harder they had to make up for
their colleagues who were laid off or
the people who were not rehired during
the recession and in fact that happened
and Catherine Shaw one of my colleagues
at the Business School and one of our
former students who's now at the
University of Utah Chris Naunton
and I have been doing a study looking at
that specifically in the context of a
firm where we can actually measure
productivity and we do see people
working harder during the recession
perhaps as a result of their being
somewhat more afraid that they'll lose
their jobs and they want to protect
their jobs and are willing to work
harder to do it the question is whether
that kind of efficiency enhancement that
occurs in a short period of time can
persist for a long time and whether that
can continue to grow and I'm doubtful so
I think these increases in productivity
that we saw for the short run are not
sustainable over the long haul in order
to get productivity to grow over the
long haul we've got to do a number of
things most of it comes from the
investment side but it means investment
in physical capital investment in human
capital that's what Stanford does we are
producers of human capital and extremely
good producers of human capital and
technology which is derived from those
two so I think that's the that's the
formula for the long run it's not making
people work harder